[Music]
Intel Arc has some downsides like this
you may need to upgrade your PC for this
game but it's improved a lot in the last
year and they're now launching the a580
which is
$180 and interestingly its closest
competitor might be the a750 also from
Intel which we just checked and that's
$190 depending on where you look so that
alone uh presents kind of a challenge
for the new a580 we got this card in
yesterday the day it launched and uh
We've turned the review around in about
24 hours to get you some detail on what
it makes sense to buy it's closest
competition other than the a750 would be
the RX 6600 so Intel at this point uh
has done pretty well to stabilize its
drivers it had major issues like we just
showed actually that's a that's one
that's still there that's for Starfield
and a lot of those issues were with
directx9 games and then directx11 games
and Intel has been working almost game
by game to try and Patch it up and get
the drivers to a point where overall the
card can be recommended to someone who
might not have troubleshooting
experience that's been the challenge for
Intel and it is competing with large
players in the market who have mountains
of last generation gpus that are getting
dumped for relatively cheap now compared
to what the market has been and so for
the a580 this is a difficult entry point
but a critical one because there haven't
been sub $200 gpus that have been
relevant for quite some time now
probably the most recent stuff we've had
has been like 16 series gpus as in
basically 20 and maybe the 3050 kind of
but other than that you have to go back
ways to get to things like the 6400 so
Nvidia has functionally abandoned this
market for now there's rumors that
they're making a 3056 gab so we're
looking forward to that disaster uh and
the
a580 has the a 750 to look to for the
closest alternative cuz it's now only
$190 depending on where you look so
they're 10 bucks apart and that's what
we're going to focus on but we have a
bunch of other cards in here too so
let's get started before that this video
is brought to you by the thermal T
swappable blade fans available in 120
and 140 mm sizes the new thermal T fans
include three sets of swappable blades
so that even as you change builds or
cases you can ensure the LEDs are always
presented on their best side the
swappable blades allow Builders to get
the fan frame out of the way of the
lights by reversing the blade direction
to reconfigure the fan as push or pull
while keeping the struts relatively
hidden and keeping the fan frame
oriented One Way swapping blades is done
by applying pressure evenly to opposite
sides then pressing until the click each
fan also has pin to- pad connections for
caess daisy chaining and you can learn
more at the link in the description
below first up for the a580 we are using
the latest drivers Intel had drivers it
knew were coming for launch but it
didn't make them available till launch
fortunately because our our card got
lost in the mail um we were able to run
with version 4887 for the Intel drivers
at time of filming those are brand new
they're supposed to include some
Starfield improvements that are like
triple digit percentage uplift or
something like that although you can't
divide by zero being unplayable before
so we'll see to quickly recap the spec
so uh the Intel Arc a580 GPU it's on Al
Miss that's their current architecture
it runs 3072 shading units has an 8 mbte
uh cache memory capacity and type come
out to 8 GB gddr6 on a 256bit memory bus
so that's good in the sense of memory
bandwidth here uh should be able to keep
Pace a little better than some of the
other low-end cards but compared to the
a750 it's a lower TDP it has a reduction
in Shader count from 3584 units down to
this 3072 number and likewise it has a
drop and rck TOs and tmus for testing we
retested the a750 everywhere we didn't
retest the a770 most places those
numbers the a750 uh we last tested these
cards in like I think it was September
for some games and then it was August
for others and the numbers haven't
really moved so there's a few specific
games where there have been changes and
we'll talk about those but for the most
part it's been very stable and there's
not a lot of uh retesting required
because it's all looking about the same
but we reran the a750 just in case and
because frankly we wanted to test with a
partner model 750 cuz we used a partner
model uh a 580 so we have the sparkle
orc here uh and uh we also have the
sparkle Titan not an Nvidia Titan just
to be clear but these are the two we ran
this was the 750 model and that's where
they get interesting because of the $190
pricing versus the uh well depending on
which 750 you get anyway but 190 to 200
versus the 180 Mark now more
traditionally this 750 has been close to
like 230 but even still so a lot of our
judgment here is going to depend on what
that price Gap is couple other quick
references before we start so the 7600
is typically around $240 to
$250 and then the RX 6600 is around 200
to 210 at the moment and Nvidia we're
not really worried about right now
because hopefully they'll have something
in this price class soon it's just the
the 3050 would be the most relevant and
uh it's not it's not really going to it
doesn't outperform any of the others
that were testing today which we would
recommend instead so let's get into the
gaming we'll talk power as well power is
pretty interesting because the a58 is
wildly inefficient uh almost in a
surprising way compared to its
competitors but we'll talk about that
start with gaming falers Gate 3 is up
first this is one of the newest games to
our test suite and it works great for
cards that are below the $400 price Mark
anything above that tends to hit
bottlenecks on the CPU especially the
lower resolutions as we we settle into
the upcoming chart though remember that
Intel had difficulty running balers Gate
3 with the direct X API which is the
default for the game we talked about
this in our balers gate GB review that
you can find on the channel already but
Vulcan performed significantly better on
Ark and in ways which weren't replicated
on other cards Arc had serious frame
pacing problems with direct X so here's
that chart we'll start with the like for
like comparison the a580 with Vulcan its
best and most appropriate use case for
Intel allowed the a750 with Vulcan a
lead of 5 to 6% we also retested this
with the newest drivers and we had the
same exact result also like for like the
direct X result for the a580 had it
below the RTX 2060 and the RX 6600 with
this 6600 carrying a significant lead
and low performance everything in the
80s is hitting a CPU bind at some point
so let's move on in balers Gate 3 at
1440p the Intel a580 orc ran at 56 FPS
average with Vulcan that has the a580
ahead of the
6600 sft we're still not sure what a sft
is but we hope to one day find out what
a sft is anyway missing vowels aside the
lead is mostly a technicality in average
FPS but the lows are better but this is
Vulcan for Intel and dx11 which is uh
closer like for like here the 6600 leads
the a580 by 9% let's stick with the like
for like for Vulcan for a second the
a750 ran at 64 FPS average and that led
the a580 is 56 FPS average result by 15
% that's a more significant Gap than we
saw at 1080p which is because the a750
was occasionally brushing against the
CPU limit Starfield went terribly for
Intel we used the drivers that claimed
triple digit uplift for Ark but
considering the Baseline was literally
not working at all maybe that's an easy
way to get three digits in our testing
we observed 18 FPS average and lows that
were completely unplayable the game was
a stuttery disaster comparisons don't
even make sense here because it just
broke Bren right now maybe it'll work
better soon as Intel has noted it's
still working on improvements here
Bethesda is working on updates as well
but as of right now it just basically
doesn't work in Total War Warhammer 3
before we make the move to Pharaoh the
game ran at 85 FPS average on the a580
at 1080p that has the a750 sparkle card
about 82% ahead of the new a580 lows are
scaling as we'd expect with the average
here so nothing out of the ordinary
there and depending on the price at the
time you're buying if these cards are
further apart it may be worth going for
the a580 it's getting a lot of the
performance uh so depending on that
price reduction it could be worth it but
if the cards are within say $10 to $20
of each other the a750 appears
worthwhile that however ignores
everything else it's only looking at ARC
the a580 is ahead of the older RTX 2060
but given the importance of the 2060s
former $300 positioning for the KO it's
a good spot for the a580 to be in if a
generation late compared to the RX 6600
the a580 leads by a 16% in average FPS
with lows similar it's good positioning
for the a580 to look at One Price class
up the RX 7600 which these days is $230
to $250 is at 101 FPS average that has
it leading the a580 by 18% while costing
about 33% more on average at 1440p what
we want to know is whether the scaling
Remains the Same the a580 leads the RTX
2060 by 14% here almost identical to the
1080p lead against the 6600 it's 25%
ahead a larger Gap than the 16% lead at
1080p the Intel Arc card is doing
relatively well scaling as resolution
increases although it's still ultimately
more of a 1080p gaming card but that's
useful information to have the a750
Titan meanwhile leads by about 133% up
at 62 FPS average The 1080ti Remains a
familiar phase here except with
significantly improved lows over some of
its immediate neighbors looking between
the a580 and the a750 Titan we land
stand on the RX 7600 right in the middle
at 62 FPS average the same 133% lead
over the a580 and Shadow of the Tomb
raater at 1080p the a580 ran at 98 FPS
average allowing the a750 Titan to
establish a 5% lead over the newer a580
if this were more consistently the Gap
then the cheaper card would be the clear
winner 5% is not a lot but it's not a
consistent Gap it changes based on the
game the RX 6600 however leads both with
its result at 125 FPS average gapping
the a580 by a relatively massive 28% as
long as there's price proximity between
these two cards at least in this game
and as long as the 6600 is still
available it would be the Clear Choice
for more expensive comparisons the RX
7600 pushes further ahead with a 54%
Advantage the RTX 460s 157 FPS average
result is a little further ahead still
and one note here everything at or above
230 FPS average would be CPU bound since
we're at 1080p so uh those wouldn't
really be directly comparable and we've
removed the cards like the 700 XTX XT
the 4070 TI and similar at 1440p the
a580 74 FPS average haded about 5 FPS
behind the a750 giving the a750 a 6 1.2%
lead that's more than we saw at 1080p so
they're getting more distant as
resolution increases but not in a
relevant way the RX 6600 is 83 FPS
average has a 12% ahead of the a580 here
so again if they're the same price the
6600 if this is consistent would be the
better buy but we'll look at other games
too the $20 Gap gives us more to
consider and we'll need the full picture
to make a determination at the end
spending around $100 more would put you
35% ahead in performance if you bought
the RX 7600 instead which also pulls up
its lows although the a580 is lows in
this game aren't a problem it's just
scaling proportionally going to the 4060
would increase that Gap by a couple
percentage points but increase the
dollar amount more significantly of
course in Final Fantasy 14 at 1080p the
a580 find its place at a high frame rate
and a less intensive game the 154 FPS
average result positions it about 52%
ahead of the RTX 2060 you shouldn't of
course change from a 2060 to an a580
it's not really an upgrade uh but it
gives us a good idea for industry Trends
in this price class and again it's a
couple Generations old intel was
probably expecting to ship around one
generation after that card so it gives
us a good idea of where they were
positioning the RX 6600 is about tied
with the a580 on this one although the
a580 pushes better lows uh We've noticed
that AMD cards in general run
disproportionately low for 1% in this
game it's not a particularly bad or
stuttery result but it definitely is
worse than what we measured on the
compared inti car the a750 leads the
a580 by almost 8% here a little more
than we've seen in some of these other
games and as for the 7600 its 20%
leadership puts it in an entirely
different class of card but so does the
price tag that or the 4060 would be the
next logical major Step Up receive you
bound at 1080p starting at the 470 so
removes everything else 1440p is next
the a580 can still play Final Fantasy at
this resolution landing at 93 FPS
average that has it just barely ahead of
the 6600 and average more in lows and
still about 7% ahead of the RTX 2060
spending more for the a750 would get you
an increase of 14% with the 7600
reducing its lead to about 19% not much
of a change and mostly within error
Horizon zero Dawn is next at 1440p the
A5 580 73 FPS average allowed the a150
Titan a lead of about 7 to 8% in average
FPS the RX 6600 is technically behind
the a580 but they're well within
run-to-run variants even the lows are
about the same rendering the 6600 and
the a580 functionally equivalent in our
benchmarking here the a580 is lead over
the 2060 is 8 to 9% here again showing
that it's positioned as one of the more
proper successors given the price
reduction and slight performance boost
but again there's that multigenerational
Gap in F1 2022 at 1080p the Intel a580
ran at 120 FPS average with the freshly
retested RX 6600 at 126 to lead of 5% in
average FPS for the 6600 although it's a
bit behind and 1% lows they 750 was 12%
ahead in this test with the RX 7600 22%
ahead of the a580 at 1440p The a580
Falls to 91 FPS average with the a750
now 9% ahead so that's a slight
reduction for the A7 50 the RX 6600 is
behind the a580 here allowing the new
Intel GPU a lead of 4.8% so they flipped
spots with the resolution increase we'll
look at some quick R tracing numbers to
close things out on the gaming side in
Tomb Raider with rt Shadows the r a58
managed about 60 FPS average at 1080p
with the highest RT settings considering
the equivalence with the 6600 here and
the close proximity to the recently
retested a750 Titan we'd say this is
great relative positioning for the a580
it allows the a750 Titan again with
brand new data a lead of 9% but that's
similar to what we saw on rasterization
so given the a580 is cut down spec
that's not bad at 1440p the a580 Led the
RX 6600 once again it's proving itself
here as compared to earlier results and
the a750 5 FPS average lead isn't
unexpected but overall the a580 is doing
relatively well an F1 2022 with rt
enabled the a580 once again performed
pretty well it's encroaching on the RX
7600 here the a750 has a 14% lead in
this one similar to what we saw in some
of the rasterization tests the RX 6600
remains behind the a580 giving it an
advantage in this particular title with
rton finally we'll run some thermal
tests this is contingent first on the
power that the Silicon pulls and second
on how good the cooler from the board
partner is so that'd be Sparkle part of
the job the a580 orc ended up at about
68° cus for the GPU core temperature
when at steady state there's really no
problem with that even if your ambient
were significantly higher than our 21c
test environment that' still leave
plenty of room and with v bio's thermal
targets the way they are probably the
fans would just spin up more these lower
end gpus tend to run relatively cool so
even in spite of the inefficient
performance the power consumption we saw
the total power consumption remains more
than manageable from a thermal
perspective thermals were about 78° C
for the memory temperature that's well
within spec it's warmer than we'd like
to see on something like say a 4090
which often has massive heat sinks but
that's fine on a card like this one
especially because it doesn't really
have that much more room to get hotter
from a power perspective because it's
pretty much at the limits anyway you're
not going to be forcing more power into
this particular silicon testing the a580
for power consumption now we found that
the card pulls 218 Watts from the pcie
cables and the pcie slot combined that
makes it one of the least power
efficient cars cards we've tested
anytime recently the Nvidia RTX 470
blows it away for power to Performance
as does Intel's own a750 which itself
wasn't particularly efficient uh and
pulled 234 Watts but it's more efficient
than the 580 the RX 6600 only pulled 136
watts in the same test making it
significantly more power efficient Intel
has a lot of work to do on this front it
seems that Intel is in amd's Old habit
from Generations past where it's
blasting power to keep up with competing
Hardware fortunately for Intel at the
lower end that's not as limiting as at
the high end because power although in a
relative sense it matters in an absolute
sense is when it gets really important
if they were blasting that say 500 watts
or something high end but this is still
Intel's next most important area of
improvement after driver support as
evidenced by a Starfield drivers are
still the primary point of concern
because people need to be able to play
games at least within the month that
they launch we normally don't report on
idle power consumption we collect it but
it's not typically that interesting in
this truncated chart we see the a580 was
pulling 43 Watts when idle on desktop
the a750 was at 45 Watts it's a lot of
heat for a passive computer by
comparison the 470 was around 11 Watts
here with the 6600 at 8 watts now to be
very clear on something one of the other
reasons we don't typically report on
idle power consumption is because it's
very hard to get a meaningful difference
one to the next just because idle is a
curious state with windows so 8 watts to
15 watts we'd call that kind of a wash
it's maybe a a testing variance
possibility but once you're talking
eight or 15 watts or 20 watts versus 40
that is a real difference and Intel is
inefficient here too for those wondering
this is a single monitor setup we know
that multim monitor sometimes causes
different issues so if it's really a $10
difference if you're set on Arc and
you're looking at a 750 versus a 580 and
it's 10 bucks we do think you should go
to the a750 the a580 strikes us as a
card you know if this follows Intel's
Trend we really wouldn't be surprised if
within a couple months the 580 is like
$160 card or something or 150 even uh
which is what it feels like it probably
should be uh or maybe was intended to be
but that's not what it is right now so
with a $10 difference it really sticking
with Arc would make sense to go to 750
it's not always a massive uplift
sometimes you're talking like 5%
commonly 8% but we are occasionally
seeing double digit uplift it just
depends on the game of the scenario then
for Alternatives if you're open to them
the RX 6600 is clearly the one most
worth considering uh ever since the
6600s price began to drop sometime over
a year ago now or something it has been
a a a key choice for us in this segment
the 200ish dollar segment now for Intel
so we talked about this in our original
Intel Arc reviews some things have
improved actually lot of things have
improved uh One Thing Remains the Same
though which is there's kind of a
certain audience that really makes sense
for an arc card and it's going to be
someone probably in our audience or
similar where somebody who is capable of
doing some self troubleshooting and you
know if it doesn't work with the newest
game like Starfield as a great example
you're okay with that so that's that's
really what you need to make peace with
if you're buying Ark they have
significantly improved the drivers we're
very impressed with how far they've come
in such a short time that doesn't change
the fact that at a consumer level if you
only are going to have one video card uh
you're not particularly good at
troubleshooting or you're buying for
someone
who shouldn't be troubleshooting or
working on their own computer then uh
those are the the factors that would
maybe push us to say maybe consider AMD
or Nvidia instead especially the 6600
but if you're okay with occasionally
being frustrated or you just don't play
the newest games then sure go for it now
the biggest beta testing period is
mostly over so dx9 stuff has largely
been updated improved and fixed dx11 has
gotten big fixes so the the people who
did the grunt work of dealing with large
amounts of unplayable games or just
stuttery messes they were before you at
this point if you haven't bought Arc yet
it's just you're still going to be in
that early adopter area for Intel uh so
what they've done is impressive RT
performance is also promising that the
price we may talk about that more later
in a future video as we add more RT
stuff to the suite but for now we think
at this price categories between really
the 750 and the 6600 for the most part
if you look at Nvidia the 4060 is the
newest sort of
cheapest in any kind of proximity uh
alternative and that's at like 300 bucks
so um otherwise we're kind of waiting on
them to do a 4050 or equivalent or you
have to go back a generation or two so
that's it for this one thanks for
watching as always subscribe for more oh
one more thing power efficiency the a580
is massively
inefficient but it's a low enough power
envelope in total that fortunately it's
not quite as bad in terms of percentage
against a a larger number like a 4090
type class card anyway that's it so
subscribe for more go to store.net
support us directly like by buying one
of our mod bats we turn this review
around really fast to try and get the
buying information out for you in case
you were considering buying one of these
and uh hopefully that's helpful but
we'll be back with more very soon we've
been posting a lot lately so check the
channel and you can also go to
patreon.com Gamers Nexus to help us out
we'll see you all next time